Hey guys, Pete here.
Today I'm going to do a Dark video to follow
up my family trees video from last year.
At the end of that video I mentioned how many
unanswered questions we have about the family
connections in Netflix's Dark.
This video will look at those with some of
the popular theories that surround them.
I'm going to talk about everything we know
with plenty of speculation, so this will contain
spoilers if you haven't made it through the
first two seasons of Dark.
This would be your chance to leave if you
wandered in here by mistake.
The day after I made my video about the families
the team behind Dark released this official
family tree.
Thiers looks great, but it didn't really add
any extra information to the dozens of fan
made ones that were already out there on the
internet.
Beyond the arrangements of the characters
what was really interesting about this one
was the question marks they added in some
of the places.
They really draw your attention to some of
the people we don't know.
I'm going to go around the family tree and
talk about each of those question marks, some
of the underlying mysteries, and the theories
people have about these complicated family
connections.
We're obviously moving into new territory
in season 3, so this will only be discussing
the families in the Winden we spent the first
two seasons of Dark getting to know.
We can start at the bottom, and the first
big question is who is Regina's father?
Claudia is a central figure in the story in
her role at the power plant, her time as a
traveller, and she earns the moniker of the
White Devil because of her influence in her
old age.
The fact that they haven't revealed her the
father of her child seems intentional at this
point, and out of all different questions
the popular theory for this one is pretty
solid.
Most fans would agree that Tronte Nielsen
is the best candidate because we know they
had a relationship.
They knew each other as kids, and it's hinted
that they had an affair as adults based on
their interaction at the power plant.
His wife was actually ready to leave him before
Mads disappeared because she knew he was cheating.
There's several questions surrounding Tronte
as a character and we'll get into that later.
But, here's what we know for him for sure
- he's married to his wife Jana, and the father
of Mads who went missing in the 1980s timeline.
His other son is Ulrich Nielsen who is the
father of Magnus, Martha, and Mikkel in the
2019 timeline.
So if Tronte is Regina's father that would
connect the Nielsen and Tiedemann families.
Mikkel Nielsen travelled through time and
was taken in by Ines Kahnwald.
That connects the Nielsens and the Kahnwalds,
and more importantly Jonas to Martha.
Since Martha and Mikkel were siblings that
makes her Jonas's aunt.
The next question mark is in the Kahnwald
family.
Who is Daniel's wife and why is she important?
We've had mention of her in his conversations
with Egon at work, and we know their daughter.
I think in this case it's hard to come up
with theories since we don't know why or even
if she's important to the big picture.
It's notable that they haven't revealed her
identity, and that they made the choice to
add a question mark here on this family tree.
After all we don't know who Hannah's mother
is, but her father Sebastian Kruger doesn't
have a question mark where his wife's name
would be.
One female character that might be a candidate
is Silja.
She fits in somewhere, and there's a possibility
that she might have a child in season 3 - which
I talked about in my the End is the Beginning
video, but there isn't enough groundwork to
turn this into a solid theory.
Silja is a mysterious character.
We know she is Elisabeth's sign language interpreter
in the 2050s timeline, and we know from this
blurb on the darknetflix2053 Instagram account
that Elisabeth is also her foster mother.
Her image appears on Adam's big photo wall
below the main families off to the side of
Noah and Agnes.
That hints that there might be more to learn
about her but doesn't tell us much else.
The other place she might fit in is in the
Doppler family line.
We don't know who Peter's mother is yet.
In this case most of the theories revolve
around where Peter came from since he arrived
in Winden in 1987, and if Helge is actually
his father in the first place.
Based on his diminished state some fans have
questioned if he would have been able to father
a child.
The simple answer is of course he could.
Helge wasn't a bright kid, his mother was
cold and possibly cruel, and he certainly
experienced trauma at the hands of Ulrich
as a child.
None of the really translates to him being
unable to have a relationship though, and
we don't know what he was like as a young
man in the 33 year gap.
He was manipulated into doing terrible things
by Noah, and it's possible that that wasn't
his only interaction with travellers.
Peter's strange backstory of coming to come
to town in 1987 without any other details
has led some fans to speculate that he's a
time traveller himself.
It's certainly possible, and the fact that
his teenage photo on Adam's wall is in black
and white makes you wonder.
The thing that contradicts this is that he
seemed unaware of time travel before he witnessed
Mad's dead body arriving at the bunker.
You could say that maybe he travelled as a
child like his wife Charlotte, so he didn't
have a memory of it, but then what is the
point of having him arrive in 1987.
Before we move on to the biggest question
I have it's worth pointing out that Greta
Doppler hinted that Helge might not be Bernd's
biological son.
As far as we can tell he raised him as he
was, but Greta told Noah that he was not conceived
by love.
The theory is that she may have been raped,
but there isn't any evidence pointing to a
prime suspect.
That leads us to the last question mark, and
arguably the biggest question of all - who
is the father of Tronte Nielsen?
His mother Agnes is also a mystery, and we
don't know who her parents are either.
She's Noah sister.
We saw her as a child in the 1920s timeline,
and she returned to Winden in the 1950s timeline
renting a room with Egon and Doris Tiedemann.
There's been a lot of speculation about who
Noah and Agnes's parents were.
One of the most popular theories is that it's
Magnus and Franziska.
We know they do travel to the past, we know
they're part of Sic Mundus in the early days,
putting them in the right place, but it seems
odd when we meet Noah and Agnes that they're
being raised by Erna rather than their parents
who are in that same time.
If this was the case the Nielsen family would
be a loop like the Doppler's.
which it would be connected to through Franziska.
We Agnes and Tronte arrive she described her
husband to Doris as a pastor that wasn't a
good man.
Tronte had mysterious burns on his arm that
were never explained.
They look like cigar burns.
And, could be signs of self-harm, or signs
of an abusive father.
As far as who that father is?
The most popular theory has been that it is
Bartosz.
This is primarily because he is an important
character that we imagine would pair up with
someone.
In my mind he doesn't seem like someone who
would burn their child, but as mentioned we
don't really know what's going on with the
injuries.
They do factor into the most recent theory,
which is that the new character who appears
as a trio in the new trailers could be Tronte's
father.
In the little bit of footage we've seen we
see the characters come off as menacing, and
they may be capable of harming children.
At the same time we don't know much about
them, so it's really just a guess at this
point.
Either way this new version of the family
tree that showed up in the trailer brings
up a lot of questions because it's mirrored
in the middle and joined with an infinity
sign.
Agness is the character who is connected to
that sign with her son branching off from
there.
This has led people to think perhaps whoever
is Agnes's mate is maybe involved with whatever
happened to cause these two worlds to split
off in the first place.
Another thing about this family tree that
I won't go into too deeply is the character
Boris Niewald who takes on the identity of
Aleksander Kohler, and then marries Regina
and becomes Aleksander Tiedemann who later
is running the power plant.
Boris just shows up in the woods, and you
could really make a whole video about this
so I don't want to go too far.
One of the things I know will get posted in
the comments if I don't bring it up though
is that his last name is Niewald.
Which, if you put the name Nielsen and Kahnwald
together you get Niewald.
This is a curious thing that they decided
to do.
There's definitely more to this character
than we have to learn, but I really don't
even have a favorite theory here.
I think it's safe to say that Boris was manipulated
by time travellers.
He's carrying the gun that will eventually
be used by Adam to kill Martha.
So he has a connection there.
Whether he was a traveller himself or he was
just put on his path by somebody who was working
behind the scenes for either Adam or Claudia
remains unclear.
But fans really enjoy this idea that his last
name is Niewald and some speculate that perhaps
even though Hannah is in her late forties
when she travels back in time might have a
child and may give them this name as a combination
between Ulrich's last name and hers.
Beyond that there is just one more thing I
want to mention and then I will wrap it up.
On Adam's board there's one character who
is never been identified.
I can't even really tell if it's a female
or a male.
It looks like a young girl to me, but I've
seen a lot of people refer to it as a boy
and you really can't tell.
It's above the families.
It's to the side of where the missing children
are, and I'm really curious as to who this
is.
So let me know if you have any theories about
this because it's strange that there's just
one picture on this entire thing that we can't
really agree on.
So, with that I will end it here.
I hope this clears up any additional questions
you had about the family tree.
If not, please ask them in the comments.
I'll try to answer as many as I can.
Let me know how you think each one of these
mysteries will be solved.
What your favorite theories are, and who you
are hoping is involved in the unrevealed parentage
of these characters.
Let me know what other theories you've got
kicking around in your head, and what you're
looking forward to in season 3 when it drops
in just 9 more days.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it.
Please subscribe to my channel and follow
me on Twitter or Instagram if you haven't
already.
Thanks for watching guys, I will talk to you
soon.